Hello everyone. My name is Immani. I'm
the co-founding head of AI at Cat.io.
Today I'm talking about grounded
reasoning systems uh for cloud
architecture and uh how we use multi-
aent orchestration to build an AI
copilot at K.O. But why now? Uh cloud
architecture needs reasoning uh not just
automation. uh we see that class system
are uh growing in complexity uh based on
people both users and also developers
and in terms of tools and constraints
and expectations are always on the rise
uh synistic tools uh don't scale over
the diversity of decisions that need to
be made around cloud architecture I mean
uh need systems that understand debate
and justify and also plan uh in order to
solve such problems and this is not
automation this is uh
reasoning. Yeah, architecture stack
isn't uh just technical. It's also the
very cognitive uh architects don't just
assemble infrastructure. They are
constantly negotiating tradeoffs based
on uh how defined the requirements are
or how much they time they have or what
resources are available for building uh
the application that they are supposed
to deliver and uh they rely on a
scattered and implicit uh context in
order to make this decision and
capturing this for AI requires
understanding how architects think. So
uh where AI meets architecture there are
three challenges that we uh capture at
CATO at a higher level in order to uh uh
solve architecture design problems. Uh
one is about requirement understanding.
So uh where are these requirements
coming from in what format? Uh and uh
what are the important pieces? how uh
global or uh specific they are. Uh these
are the thing all the things that need
to be understood as a value
requirements. On the other slides about
architecture identification uh there are
many many different components that
could exist in an architecture. Uh but
uh based on the components and based on
where where they are they could have
very different functions. In order to
understand how an architecture works
knowing different functionalities and uh
and the functions that different
components are playing is very important
too. And uh putting all these things
together is about architecture uh
recommendation is that so we know the
requirements we understand what the
architecture state is today. what are
the recommendation that uh need to be
pro uh provided in order to uh either
match requirements or improve the
architecture uh to uh to to be uh
matching uh best
practices. Uh to turn these problems
into more specific AI related challenges
uh what we're dealing with is is a mix
of semantic and graphics context. On one
side we have requirements which are
mostly text textual uh documents and on
the other side it's architecture which
is inherently graph data. How we can uh
make these two different sources of data
to come together and and make the right
connections in order to higher uh level
of reasoning is very important and
through that comes complex reasoning
scenarios. uh the the kind of questions
that come in could be very complex, very
vague, very broad and uh that needs to
be broken down into different parts and
uh be planned properly in order to uh uh
uh get the right answer to to the uh
question. And above all of these things,
uh how we evaluate and uh provide
feedback to such a uh uh large AI system
that has many uh different uh moving
parts. Uh so uh we want to go through uh
uh these challenges and share some of
our learnings uh uh what uh we have
experienced and uh what we have done and
uh and we are what we are doing in order
to uh improve to to the next uh level.
So the first one is about about
grounding age agents in a specific
context. So Ellen uh needs proper
context uh about architecture tourism
effectively uh translating natural
language into meaningful architecture
retrieval task isn't straightforward and
also providing it fast makes it even
harder. Uh so we we tried multiple
things here both on architecture
retrieval and on requirement retrieval
part. uh one was that uh it was about
semantic enrichment of architecture data
for each component. We uh collected uh
enough relevant semantic information to
enrich uh that component in order to
make it uh more searchable and uh uh
findable in vector
search. Another part was about uh graph
enhance component search. when you're
searching for a specific component or a
type of component within an
architecture. Uh through graph search,
we also uh use all sorts of graph uh
algorithms in order to make sure that we
retrieve the right uh pieces of
information from an
architecture. Uh for requirements
specifically uh we did some early score
enrichment of requirement documents for
faster retrieval because uh requirements
uh could be about many different topics
and uh uh if we want to do uh and
understand a large corpus of text
properly probably want to understand
different concept that exists in that uh
in that context. Uh we did uh something
uh a little simpler in our first
iteration uh which was about uh figuring
out what are the important concepts and
requirements for us within a large
organization and based on that we scored
different documents and and through that
uh we made retrieval task uh faster.
What we learned was that semantic
grounding improves reasoning but doesn't
always uh work. uh we we we saw some
really good results of architecture
retrieval. However, we also saw uh where
it falls short and cannot be scaled or
gets uh very detailed uh
responses. Wrong design is critical in
soft grounding. We we cannot always
provide uh the exact uh the exact
structure and uh telling the agent to uh
to exactly what to focus on and and what
to retrieve is very important and uh the
other part is that that uh graph memory
supports uh continuity and not just
accuracy. It is very important that uh
we in our graph searches we are able to
uh find different nodes within a graph
but also be able to connect these
different nodes and figure out why these
we have these different nodes uh popped
up in our searches and and add more
context that could help us to do proper
reasoning uh in the next steps. So what
we see here for example is one of our
early designs on uh architecture
retrieval. On the on the left side we
have um uh storing step on the on the
right side you have the query step and
uh on the left step uh we're basically
breaking the architecture down by
components and turning the the JSON data
into natural language and then enriching
it with connection data and embedding it
and putting into vector DB and on the
other side uh when the search time comes
a query comes uh we embed that search in
the vector uh DB
and find uh the component. Uh we saw
some uh good results with this. But uh
as as one thing we uh we we uh we found
was that uh semantic search doesn't work
very well for uh uh this type of graph
data and it has its own limitation. And
that's why uh from here we went more
towards uh graph- based uh searches.
First of all, enrich this approach with
with some graph uh searches and from
here we are moving towards uh making
this more uh based on the graph uh a
knowledge graph. This is another design
that we did initially for uh
understanding requirements and uh uh
part of it is uh very uh familiar uh for
most of us which is about uh taking in
documents split uh pre-processing it
splitting it embedding it. uh what what
we did extra here was uh coming up with
uh first of all having requirement
templates uh that uh had specific
structure on what requirements are. Uh
in this way we were able to uh basically
structure what we are extracting from
the documents uh in order to the uh as
we call it pods to to make sure that the
the extracted information is relevant to
what we're going to use
downstream. This helped us uh with fast
retrieval. it has uh the its own
advantage in terms of uh finding uh
structuring the the business
requirements and finding the the right
pieces uh for uh agents to to do the
further the uh recommendation tasks. Uh
however we also learned that this is
also had some limitation as we increase
the number of documents we we see that
we we sometimes lose the context u uh in
uh in a larger uh searches. So and here
is another part that uh finding uh the
right context within larger corpus
becomes very important and uh that's
where we see some uh graph analysis
could also help on this
side. Another part is about complex
reasoning scenarios. Good design
involves uh conflicting goals,
trade-offs and debates. That's part of
the architecture design world. Uh it
doesn't it never comes easy. Uh and we
also need the agents that can
collaborate, argue and converge on uh
justified
recommendations. Uh so what we tried was
uh basically building a mass archite
orchestration uh with ro specific
agents. This multi- aent system uh is
able to basically uh make multiple
agents uh work uh together at the same
time and uh give them multiple
properties. We'll we'll cover more of
that and and next slides. Uh another
thing that we tried was uh having
structured message format. Initially uh
that we had to start with uh generating
XMLs and parsing XMLs which wasn't fun
and I'm glad those days are gone. Um and
uh but having the structured message
definitely helped uh with uh building
better workflows and and h having
multiple agents to work with each other
uh and having more agents also uh work
with each other in a in a longer chain.
Um, customer management was a was an
important piece because the way that we
wanted to uh h how have the agents
collaborate with each other because
there were multiple levels of uh
interaction between agents. uh we wanted
to sure make sure that the uh
conversations are isolated to first of
all make sure that uh we don't waste
tokens and plus we have uh done some we
had done some experimentations that
increasing the memory showed increase of
hostination in the in the results. So we
decided to keep the memory isolated uh
between
agents. Uh cloning of agents uh for
parallel processing for certain task was
a was an important piece that we did and
and helped us to
um speed up some of our processes. Um
and uh that record also some memory
management in order to like what do we
uh duplicate for uh agents uh from a
certain point that decide to do the
cloning um and how we manage the memory
as that cloning point and what we
learned was that uh structured outputs
improves clarity and control. It's super
super important to to do structured
outputs uh for better programming. Uh we
hear a lot also about how structured
output could reduce uh the the the
reasoning abilities of the the model.
Um it is a real trade-off but however uh
the we are seeing very good results with
the level of structured output that we
have.
uh mass let uh mass let agents resolve
trade-offs uh dynamically and not just
uh execute static uh plans. Uh we we let
we give a lot of uh uh we we are working
also on different ways of orchestration
uh for for agents and what are they
exactly doing each each step that
they're taking uh as part of their
interaction with other agents.
uh but uh we're learning that uh the the
more dynamic we make it uh the the
higher creativity showing and planning
and uh reaching a results and that's uh
what we are trying to
optimize. Uh another thing is that
successful mass orchestration does
require control flow uh control flows.
But it's not possible
to have multiple agents to just work
with each other and uh
uh hope for the best that that that the
result is going to come at the end. Uh
so
uh the major part of our stack that is
in production and working is
recommendation that is based on multiple
agent systems. uh as we see there's
here's a screenshot of uh some of the
recommendations that we have on some uh
mockup data uh but everything else that
that you see here in terms of the
categories uh that we have for example
architecture architecture messaging and
queuing API integration uh and so on and
for each of these uh the multi- aent
system comes up uh with multiple uh
recommendations and each recommendation
is broken down into different parts such
as description, target state, gap
analysis that shows for example what the
requirements was, what did what the
agents couldn't find in the architecture
based on their requirements and uh what
are the recommendation recommended
actions in terms of filling out uh the
the discovered
gaps. Um the system that we have that
that does this is a um has multiple
agents in it. So one is a chief
architect that uh basically oversees and
coordinates uh higher level tasks and
then and there are 10 staff architects
uh each specialized uh in in a certain
domain for example infrastructure API IM
and so forth um and then there is uh
there are two retrievers uh requirement
retriever that
uh basically has access to requirements
data and the architecture retriever that
understands what's the current uh
architecture state and can answer
questions about what components are
there and so
forth. Uh the mass workflow that we have
is uh is like this that uh there are
basically three main tasks that uh that
happen in a a sequence in order to uh
generate recommendations at the end of
the slow. Uh one is list generation
where uh at the end of it we have a list
of possible recommendations and then
there is conflict conflict resolution
which is about uh um having the chief uh
architect looking at the uh generated
list of recommendations in order to um
in order to figure out if they're in
conflict or if there are redundancies
and so uh uh and so on. and uh basically
the prune the list of re recommendations
in order to uh go further down the
workflow. And the last step is design
proposal which uh is uh basically
writing a full-on uh design proposal
based on each recommendation topic in
terms of again uh what are the gap uh
analysis that has been done uh what are
the proposals in terms of improvement of
the architecture and so on. And the way
it works is that uh there is a chief
architect and the chief architect
requests a list of recommendations from
staff architect uh and uh and the staff
architect in order to do that it reaches
out to uh sends requests to the
architecture state agent and the
requirements agent and uh these calls
happen in parallel. uh they they happen
a number of times based on the budgets
that exist and that at some point uh it
all comes back to the staff and staff uh
gets back to the chief with a list of uh
possible uh recommendations. Um and this
also happens among multiple staff
architects. So uh this could be tens of
calls that happen at the same time. And
then after after resolving the conflicts
uh we go again uh back to the staff
architect in order to uh generate those
design proposals and again this flow
will happen. uh and this time uh there
is a cloning happening which is an
important part of uh this whole flow is
that um each staff architect is going to
be cloned uh by the number of
recommendations that's supposed to
generate and each clone has access to
the past history and uh generates its
own current history which is separated
from the other clones and this way uh
the agent has access to all the existing
knowledge in order to make sure that you
know it it kind of writes up the best uh
design proposal at the end of the
workflow. Um and
um the the last important thing here is
evaluation and feedback. Um and
uh the challenge is uh how do we know if
a recommendation is good? uh we build
this uh a multi- agent system that has
many many engines and uh there are
rounds and rounds of conversations that
that need to be
uh monitored what's going to work the
best here and uh we had to close the
loop with human scoring and structured
feedback and revision cycles.
uh what we learned especially at the
stage that we are uh the best
uh evaluation is human evaluation. Uh
and we noticed that LLM evaluations uh
are good but they do not give us what we
want in order to make the improvements
that we needed to to. Uh for that
purpose we built uh our internal human
eval tool. We called it eagle eye and uh
it basically helps us to look at every
specific case uh the architecture the
requirements that are extracted uh the
conversations between the agents and
also the uh generated require uh
recommendations and in this way uh we
are able to look at them and uh
basically do uh relevance visibility uh
and clarity studies and give them scores
um and uh and based on that make some
decisions on in terms of what we want to
focus
next. And what we learned is that
confidence is not correctness. um uh it
can help uh but it is not uh the uh uh
what what what can be trusted all the
time and human uh feedback is essential
early on when uh when when we're
building such systems from uh from
scratch and uh eval must be baked into
system design not added later. This is a
this is that
the design thought that that we that we
came down to that is that is very
helpful is that as soon as we start
thinking about uh designing a new AI
system we also start thinking about okay
what are the evaluations are going to be
around it uh and we're able to evaluate
whatever we have um as we go forward it
could be a human eval tool it could be a
monitoring dashboard or it could be uh
LM based evaluation uh feedback
loops. Um this uh is a screenshot of our
uh uh evaluation tool. Uh we basically
can see both uh various things that
about the interactions in the the
multient system and uh go through the
conversations and read them and make
sure that they make sense or not.
And uh it actually helps to do that. For
example, this is a case of hallucination
uh early on. Uh this is uh a staff
architect network security that sent a
message to requirements retriever and
uh asked for to uh for scheduling a
workshop and uh provided some uh dates
on uh when that workshop could be in
order to basically solve whatever is
trying to solve. um handling these kind
of cases is very important uh in in in
the problems and also uh as part of the
the uh structured uh output that that
each uh give and also it's it's fun uh
to to come across some of these
hallucinations uh uh mid building such
systems. Um so to wrap it up
uh about reasoning systems uh is that
it's just is it's not assistance uh and
there there is a slight difference
there. Uh building a copilot uh is not
generating answers. Uh it's about
designing a system that can reason. Uh
we want to build a system that uh can uh
have uh a good view of a large uh amount
of data especially uh such as uh
architecture data where we're talking
about thousands or millions of
components and uh large number of
documents uh that need to be in scope uh
in order to answer various kind of
questions with various types of uh
stakeholders from uh developers uh to
CTO's uh that could be interacting with
uh with uh such a
co-pilot. Uh so
uh and uh and that takes uh roles that
takes uh workflows that takes memories
and structure in order to build such a
reasoning system. uh and uh and and and
putting all these things together uh
requires uh a lot of experimentation in
terms of uh what works based on data
that exists. Uh we are learning that
based on data that we have uh there are
certain patterns that uh that work
better than the others. Uh for example,
graphs are becoming more and more
important uh in our uh in our designs
and uh you know the part of it is uh is
what kind of uh interactions agents can
have with each other and uh and uh what
level of uh autonomy we want to give to
each u agent. Uh we're learning that uh
now we've experimented with uh with
various
uh uh uh frameworks for building multi-
aents and we're coming down to using uh
uh lang graph uh for building uh some of
the agent workflows and again having uh
a manager on top of that in order to
manage these various uh line graph
workflows. uh and then uh also using
slide uh to basically handle some of
these uh higher level uh management and
uh and and and using uh uh graphs to
capture uh as part as as much of the
memory as possible in order to make sure
that the AI always has uh the right
context uh as uh you know as as per
task.
And yes and we are just getting started
and we believe this is uh this is how AI
will uh design software and uh if uh
there is any questions please feel free
to reach me uh at
ammonato.te. Thank you for attention.